STEPHANIE WONG: As your
cloud application scales,
you'll eventually be faced
with an all too common problem.
How do I maintain tight
control over network resources,
but not be a roadblock to teams
spinning up the resources they
need to do work?
In this episode of
Cloud Networking,
I show you that you can have
the best of both worlds using
shared VPCs.
Large organizations with
multiple cloud projects
value the ability
to share resources
while maintaining logical
separation between groups
or departments.
And this makes complete sense.
Centrally network
admins are on the hook
to maintain sanity for
the overall network,
so sharing resources is
critically important.
But every team
has special needs,
meaning that it's a
constant churn for admins
to have to set up new projects,
access policies, billing,
quotas, et cetera, et cetera.
If your company is large enough,
this can be a full time job.
That's why Google
created shared VPC, which
allows an organization
to connect resources
from multiple projects
to a common VPC network,
so that they can communicate
with each other securely
and efficiently using internal
IPs from that network.
When you use shared VPC,
you designate a project
as a host project and attach one
or more service projects to it.
The VPC networks in
the host projects
are called shared VPC networks.
With shared VPC,
you can centrally
manage the creation of routes,
firewalls, subnet IP ranges,
VPN connections, and more
for the entire organization,
and allow developers to own
billing, quotas, and IAM
permissions, and
autonomously operate
their development projects.
For example, imagine
you were the network
admin at an e-commerce company.
You have a single externally
facing website application
server that uses services
like personalization,
recommendation, and analytics
all internally available,
but built by different
development teams.
You can have a
shared VPC network
with a host project
and three service
projects for personalization,
recommendation, and analytics
all on different subnets.
With shared VPC, the
network and security admin
would set up the overall
security policies and the host
project, like restricting
which VMs can have public IPs
and access to the
internet by setting up
an organization
policy that disables
external IP access for VMs.
In this example, the
personalization recommendation
and analytic services.
Meanwhile, each team would
be able to start spinning up
VMs in their assigned
service project
and decide more fine
grained details,
like setting up
compute resources.
And VMs still get the same
network throughput caps and VM
to VM latency as when they're
not on shared networks.
Let's dive into how to
set up a shared VPC.
At the organizational level,
my log in, Stephanie.Wong,
currently has org admin and
shared VPC admin privileges.
I can also assign the
shared VPC admin role
to somebody else in my org.
Switching over to
my host project,
I created a custom VPC called
VPC one and two subnets,
development and production.
I also created two
firewall rules,
one to allow SSH
to all instances
in the network and one to allow
ICMP traffic between instances
in these subnets.
In the shared VPC page,
first, enable host project
to be the host project by
clicking set up shared VPC.
I'm going to select
sharing individual subnets.
This option allows you to share
specific subnets in the host
project VPC with
your service project.
Then select the VPC one
dev and prod subnets.
Let's attach two service
projects, development
and production.
Make sure the Compute
Engine API has
been enabled in each service
project before attaching them.
Here, you can edit the
default permissions
given to this service project.
Then click Save.
You can now see host
project is the shared VPC
host with two
subnets, and it has
two attached service projects.
This is also where you can add
additional host project users
and admins.
Now I'm going to log into
my development project
on our account, John, who only
has permission to that project.
Switching to the development
project, create a new VM,
and add a development tag.
Then select network shared
with me from the host projects,
so that you can
select the dev subnet.
Once it's done creating, copy
the internal IP of the instance
since you'll need
it just in a second.
Next, I'll switch
to Mary's account,
who is the owner of
the production project.
Create a new VM in
the production subnet
and add a production tag.
Making sure to change the zone
to the one in the production
subnet region, select
the prod subnet.
When both VMs are done
creating, you can see.
I can SSH into the prod instance
and ping the dev instances
internal IP address since I've
created the right firewall
rules and the host
project shared VPC.
Now you just want to make sure
that when configuring subnet IP
ranges in the same
or different regions,
you allow for sufficient IP
space between the subnets
for future growth.
Plus GCP lets you expand
an existing subnet
without affecting any
existing VM's IP address,
and with zero downtime.
How cool is that?
Shared VPC is a
powerful feature that
makes GCP more
flexible and manageable
for your organization.
Yep, that means you might
just have enough time
to go fishing on the
weekend without a fire drill
ping interrupting
that overhead cast.
To learn more, check out the
documentation link below.
And remember,
optimizing your network
means freeing up your bandwidth.
[MUSIC PLAYING]